today I want to talk about learning
slowly you know we read so much about
learning the language in three months or
in six months and books that promise you
you'll be fluent when you finish the
book and of course we all know that
that's not true and I think I suddenly
realized you know as I was walking to a
place that we had been to before
the first time we went there we were in
a hurry we didn't notice anything and it
was going to the old town but the second
time we were walking more slowly we
didn't care when we got there but we
were enjoying the surroundings we
noticed more things and I think the same
is true in language learning